[Music]
mark zuckerberg was a harvard freshman
with a gift for computer programming
less than a decade later he is the
baby-faced
multi-billionaire power broker who rubs
shoulders with the president
my name is barack obama and i'm the guy
who got mark to wear
a jacket and tie i think most people
still haven't really digested the scale
of facebook or how quickly it's grown
the goal is obviously to get to ubiquity
i mean mark zuckerberg wants
everyone to be on this service he
transformed the dorm room project
into the internet's biggest global
village the site now has
over 900 million users can't
underestimate how driven mark zuckerberg
really
is zuckerberg is just as visionary
as steve jobs he's going to prove just
as influential as
bill gates but for all that success
zuckerberg has confronted bitter battles
and lawsuits
over facebook's origins one he wanted to
control his own thing
and two if he's gonna go against someone
he's gonna crush them
we spent three months working with mark
being essentially led on we were all
blindsided we had no idea that
you know he was working on a competing
product he has waged an all-out war on
his biggest competitors facebook
and google's relationship is pretty
simple they just don't like each other
and zuckerberg has come under fire
for pushing the limits on user privacy
users have less control over private
information they don't fully know how
their information is being shared
he's not dealing with just a piece of
technology
he's dealing with people and their
behavior and in many ways he's doing it
on the fly
they have amassed this humongous
database of
information about us because we trusted
them
so the question is should we still trust
them
i think that the goal that we went into
it with wasn't to make
an online community but sort of like a
mirror for the real community that
existed in real life
mark zuckerberg we think we know him
because we've seen his life unfold in
the oscar-winning movie the social
network
the portrait was unsparing a super geek
intense cutthroat brilliant and socially
crippled
i don't understand which part but was it
accurate he's always
had friends you know he's a pretty
social guy um
i think the last time i checked 879
friends on facebook
this is the real mark zuckerberg in
rarely seen footage
shot at facebook's first corporate
headquarters by young filmmakers in
2005.
what are we celebrating it's got 3
million users 3 million users
yeah and how long has facebook been
around not that long
a little more than a year
while zuckerberg pushes the envelope on
user privacy
he opted out of participating in this
program
in 2004 at the age of 19 he created
facebook today the 28 year old ceo
has accumulated a net worth estimated at
15.5
billion dollars mark's mission from the
beginning was about
connecting people and it was clearly
based on this theory that if the world
were more connected it would be a better
place
but there's a lot of surprises when you
really dig deep into the story of
facebook the biggest single surprise is
the
peculiar and uh tenacious personality of
mark zuckerberg
and you the the depth of his convictions
and his consistency
[Music]
born in 1984 he grew up in the hudson
river town of dobbs ferry
a bedroom community north of new york
city
david kirkpatrick spent two years
researching a book about zuckerberg and
facebook called
the facebook effect he comes from an
unbelievably supportive family in which
he's the only son
and he has three sisters so he was kind
of the prince and in fact i think his
parents called him
the prince and he was treated
accordingly so this is a guy without any
problem of self-confidence
computer savvy from the start zuckerberg
taught himself the complicated computer
language
c plus and by ninth grade had created a
digital version of the board game
risk journalist jose antonio vargas
interviewed zuckerberg for his new
yorker magazine profile
he actually created a thing called
zucknet
which is an internal instant messaging
system for the family
so the computers could talk to each
other
and that's kind of the kid he was when
he got sort of
tired of his local high school he
decided to go to exeter prep school
really because he just wanted more
challenge it was at the exclusive
exeter academy that zuckerberg and his
friend adam deangelo
created a music website called synapse
it was intended to anticipate what your
preferences might be
and it was very very popular even before
he started facebook he was fending off
offers
from microsoft and others to buy synapse
for well over a million dollars
like a tech world version of an all-star
athlete
big name companies wanted to recruit him
right out of exeter
again zuckerberg was unimpressed and
chose instead
to enter harvard in 2002 where it wasn't
long before he got himself in trouble
zuckerberg hacked into the school's
computers to collect images of students
nicholas carlson is deputy editor at
businessinsider.com
you can sort of tell that he's a little
bit of a troublemaker he creates
something called
face mash his first year in harvard and
it's a sort of hot or not for the
harvard community and then it maintained
an entire list of harvard students and
which ones were the most attractive
ranking them by hotness
ellen mcgirt interviewed zuckerberg for
fast company magazine
face mash worked in kind of a a little
bit of an icky way
it made people upset obviously people
felt mocked or exposed
and it was one of the first big
experiences that mark had with
the privacy issues of the masses
under pressure zuckerberg shut down the
site the harvard administration board
charged him with breaching security
violating copyrights and violating
individual privacy but by then facemash
was a campus sensation
zuckerberg had seen his future at the
same time
getting trouble for the building this
mischievous web tool
he built a mischievous web tool that was
really popular
i imagine that he had a couple of
sleepless nights worrying about how
how bad this thing was going to be it
was relieved when it all blew over
but was also incredibly curious about
what he could then
make next if you're a genius with genius
friends sitting in a dorm room
suddenly the world looks like a big
happy open place if you can just
get into that database at the time
the technology landscape was changing
dramatically
brad stone is a senior writer at
bloomberg businessweek
the internet was was really a much
different world back in 2004
friendster really demonstrates that a
social network needs to have
technical chops the site goes down all
the time it's unreliable
myspace also it's full of ads it's very
distracting it also begins to have
technical instability at harvard
zuckerberg met classmate and future
business partner
eduardo saverin author ben mesrick
is one of the few to have interviewed
saverin about the early days of facebook
eduardo met mark zuckerberg in an
underground jewish fraternity
the underground scene at harvard you
know these were not really
fun events these were kind of strange
little social settings really bad
parties
mostly all guys and so eduardo and mark
met
in this scene um and they became friends
pretty quickly because they were both
kind of outsiders
facemash got zuckerberg noticed by three
insiders
upperclassmen building a social
networking site called harvard
connection
olympic rowers and twins cameron and
tyler winklevoss
with partner divia narendra
harvard connection was an idea that i'd
come up with when i was a junior in
college
since at the end of 2002. the team had
been building the site for nearly a year
two of their original programmers had
moved on and they desperately needed a
new partner
the three of us are not computer
programmers by by trade or practice
we did need an actual programmer to
write the actual hard lines of code
and we thought mark was that guy the
trio
reached out to zuckerberg he was
enthused excited
and clearly his his eyes were lighting
up what happened next
sparked a furious battle over how
facebook was actually created
the details unfold in email exchanges
between zuckerberg
and the harvard connection team at first
zuckerberg appeared eager i read over
all the stuff you sent
and it seems like it shouldn't take too
long to implement so we can talk about
that after i get all the basic
functionality up tomorrow night
then zuckerberg began to delay the
project
december 4th sorry i was unreachable
tonight i just got about three of your
missed calls
i was working on a problem set december
10th
the week has been pretty busy thus far
so i haven't gotten a chance to do
much work on the site or even think
about it really
zuckerberg was stalling because he was
busy working on a similar social
networking site
based on harvard's student directory
called the facebook
he and severin partnered to fund it mark
came to him and said you know you put up
a thousand dollars and we'll launch this
site
and you know there were no contracts
these were just two kids in a dorm room
really
um but that's where it started writer
nicholas carlson interviewed more than a
dozen people involved in the founding of
facebook and found instant messages
retrieved from zuckerberg's computer
he said zuckerberg sent to saverin
according to business insider
the i am suggests zuckerberg was
deliberately misleading the winklevoss
twins
he says things like look at this site
that i'm working on harvard connection
haha they made a mistake they asked me
to do it for them
because i'm working on my own facebook
we were always
under the impression that mark was
working on harvardconnection.com
there was never an indication from him
that he could not do the work
uh didn't want to do the work or was
working on something
identical on the side called uh the
facebook
when he met with the winklevoss brothers
the last time he saw that he
probably should tell them that he's been
working on a competing product
he sort of conferred about it with
friends but in the end he said you know
what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna blank them i'm gonna blank
them in the ear
on february 4th 2004 just as he was
expected to complete work on their site
zuckerberg and his friends instead
launched the facebook
the winklevoss brothers and narendra
found out about it the same way nearly
everyone else at harvard did
it completely blindsided us we
definitely did not expect that
mark wanted to have control over his own
project he saw that they were on to
something cool
the winklevoss brothers but he saw that
he could do something cooler
and so one he wanted to control his own
thing
and two if he's going to go against
someone he's going to crush them and
that's what he did
mark zuckerberg's new harvard-based
social networking site
the facebook was mired in controversy
from the start
just days after he launched it in
february of 2004
the winklevoss twins and divia narendra
sent him a letter to cease and desist
in a nutshell our complaint against mark
zuckerberg
is fraud unjust enrichment and breach of
contract
zuckerberg responded with a letter
denying any wrongdoing
claiming his site was a separate venture
and used
none of the same code the winklevoss
twins and narendra
would later appeal a 65 million dollar
settlement with facebook
they lost in federal court but that
settlement could now be worth
200 million dollars but none of the
vicious legal wrangling
slowed the incredible momentum of the
facebook
at that point my roommates were kind of
like you know this is pretty cool like i
bet this would work at other schools
so we launched it at columbia yale and
stanford and within a couple of weeks
each of those three schools
also like had thousands of users who
were like all right this is pretty sweet
like
let's just go all out and see how many
schools we can launch the site as
quickly as possible
about this point in time um they started
to take meetings with venture
capitalists and with bigger advertisers
and this is all kind of eduardo's doing
they got a pretty early deal
with uh visa and they had a deal with
american express
they had a number of advertisers that
came and went
then record companies started getting
interested and they began to get some
pretty good revenue
from the music industry enter
sean parker who had his own connection
to the music business
on a trip to new york zuckerberg and his
partner eduardo saverin had dinner with
the 24 year old co-founder of napster
the seasoned entrepreneur and a truly
creative individual an extraordinarily
interesting person who had
worked his way into a network in the
valley that is just
to die for it particularly at that point
for zuckerberg
parker was a hero and a role model
partner saverin
didn't agree eduardo did not think
highly of sean from the very beginning
uh he thought that sean was a snake oil
salesman that they didn't need sean
that sean talked to big game but was
living out of a duffel bag and had been
kicked out of two companies
in the summer of 2004 with saverin
remaining on the east coast
zuckerberg left harvard we came out to
palo alto for this summer
just to hang out because palo alto is
kind of this mythical place where
you know all the startups come from and
got ready to launch at
another 150 schools when the year
started one of the things that mark
did that was very smart by going to palo
alto was to actually
enter the petri dish of
entrepreneurialism particularly for new
technologies
zuckerberg and his friends moved into a
large frame house with a swimming pool
and he reconnected with sean parker who
later became zuckerberg's roommate
he was the adult supervision he's the
guy who showed them how things are done
in silicon valley
he's the one who showed them how to meet
investors
how to negotiate with them who to hire
mark has told me stories of just all of
the guys
coding late at night around dining room
tables and
eating chicken mcnuggets and cereal and
there's partying going on sean parker is
bringing them around to the different
kind of
cool silicon valley hot spots and
meanwhile the website is is growing
astronomically fast i mean there's a
million member party by december of that
year
during this time parker gave zuckerberg
some shrewd advice he took to heart
he sort of looked at him and said you
need to be the founder of this thing
and you need to be the ceo forever you
know you can't turn this over to
investors and mark is able to negotiate
a series of
increasingly important investment deals
that do two things one allow him enough
operating cash
to hire some of the smartest engineers
in the business and to
help him retain majority control in the
company
but tensions began to grow with
zuckerberg's original partner eduardo
saverin who remained on the east coast
eduardo felt that you know he was the
business head of the company and he was
no longer being treated that way
you know mark and sean were taking
meetings all over california they were
meeting with venture capitalists
and they were kind of ignoring eduardo
he retaliated eduardo froze the bank
accounts to try and get mark's attention
and mark and sean began to sort of
figure out a way
to build the company without eduardo
zuckerberg responded
and froze saverin out eduardo was
removed from the company masthead
and he essentially became a non-entity
he became a non-person um he was thrown
out
and he became very upset facebook had a
million
active users on college campuses
nationwide and big money was starting to
pour in
sean parker the new president of
facebook introduced zuckerberg to
silicon valley
angel investor peter thiel who put five
hundred thousand dollars into the
company
then in the spring of 2005 the venture
capital firm
excel partners offered zuckerberg 12.7
million dollars
for an 11 stake in the company and
didn't ask for much control at all
walking away from that investment mark
controlled three out of five
board seats which is a bizarre and
unprecedented situation to have one
individual
have absolute effectively dictatorial
control over the disposition
and direction of an increasingly giant
company
overnight the excel investment gave
facebook a valuation of
100 million dollars as facebook's public
profile grew
so did zuckerberg's control this time
sean parker was edged out in august of
2005
parker was arrested for suspicion of
cocaine possession
although not formally charged with a
crime and immediately released it led to
his abrupt resignation
as president of facebook he was the
primary outside
face of the company and it was felt that
somebody who was
under any kind of a cloud with drugs was
not the right guy to be the public face
of facebook
so mark reluctantly agreed that he ought
to leave
facebook was growing with remarkable
speed and zuckerberg moved the company
from its frat-like house with the pool
to a larger and more conventional space
in downtown palo alto
but the college atmosphere remained the
same
one of the things that i do focus on
at facebook is making sure that the
culture is very friendly you know and
that
people hang out in terms of managing
this whole process
nothing you know nothing like i have no
idea what i'm doing you know
even their employee interviews were
different chris kelly was brought on in
the new position
of chief privacy officer to deal with
facebook's increasingly contentious
privacy issues
at a time when the entire company
numbered only a couple dozen employees
the first time i met mark we we climbed
out on the roof
out through the uh the window and did
our interview on the roof of
of what was then a world wraps and it
was clear he was young
but um he had a very sophisticated
understanding of what had happened so
far
and where he wanted to take the company
determined to keep facebook's unusual
creative culture alive
all night hackathons were one way to do
it we have these hackathons at the
company right where
basically everyone gets together and
just hacks on something and build
something
um all night long and the only the only
rule is that
you aren't allowed to work on at a
hackathon what you work on the rest of
the time so people work on crazy stuff
the hackathons were some of the most
kind of creative focus that you could
ever imagine
in a company imagining these incredibly
talented engineers coming together for a
night
and saying we're going to stay up all
night and we're just going to program
and
we're going to we're going to pick a
project and we're gonna get it done that
night
it's like great make it we'll prototype
it and there'll be a prototype war
and see who wins it can be a contentious
environment
oh man they wouldn't be able to get all
the way across no i disagree
that's [ __ ] we had an argument from
mark's point of view this is where good
ideas come from
quickly and efficiently good ideas were
flowing
zuckerberg then made a change that would
give facebook a sudden
and dramatic boost allowing people to
identify
or tag themselves and their friends in
photographs
that was a huge huge
change that led to massive new use of
facebook and photos became
very rapidly by far the most used part
of facebook
and became the single biggest driver of
its growth
that growth continued in one direction
up
according to facebook's internal
tracking its user base had shot
to 5.5 million users in less than two
years
and media giants were banging on the
door in 2006
yahoo baited the 22 year old zuckerberg
with an extraordinary offer
a buyout for one billion dollars
even more extraordinary zuckerberg
turned them down
now if you are a parent of someone
about mark's age you're looking at the
yahoo decision
and thinking why did you not take that
money
it's never been about money if it was it
would have just sold out
we just felt that doing that and going
down that path
would not help us build facebook out to
what we thought it could be
in 2006 mark zuckerberg rejected a one
billion dollar pitch from yahoo
when mtv pushed the ante even higher
michael j wolf was ceo of mtv networks
mark had taken me on a walk around palo
alto
and showed me his apartment
and afterwards we sat down for a lunch
and
i told him we'd be willing to pay as
much as
a billion and a half dollars to buy
facebook outright
his answer was i think it's worth a lot
more
and besides you've seen my apartment i
don't really
need that kind of money and at the same
time
i may never have an idea as good as this
one
so i'm not that interested in selling
there was internal strife
around it no question there were a lot
of people who wanted to sell
ultimately you know mark decided to turn
down the offers
zuckerberg wasn't ready to sell because
he had some ideas that he thought would
make facebook even more popular
one of them was called news feed a kind
of
real-time wire service of updates about
what users were up to
news feed is what everybody is doing at
that point or what they're posting
what they're linking to the world that
they live in which is really what a
newspaper is right
it's a living breathing newspaper of
people around you
but many facebook users thought that
newspaper sent out too much information
and violated their privacy seven hundred
and fifty thousand of them
launched an online protest to say that
it was unpopular at first is a dramatic
understatement
they were under siege at the office they
couldn't leave they were surrounded by
news trucks
almost 10 percent of our user base at
the time
joined the students against facebook
news feed group
zuckerberg was forced to apologize he
wrote his apology note himself
it was probably a good learning
experience when facebook changed some of
the privacy controls it was
an overstep i do think he takes those
seriously
but i do think that he's willing to
continue to overstep
for the for the purpose of making a
product that he wants to make the
apology
was not a surrender zuckerberg was sure
that users would get used to this new
level of sharing
and he turned out to be right after
tweaking news feed
it became one of the most popular
elements of the facebook experience
it just happened that the first time i
ever met mark was two days after that
happened
and i can tell you even though his
members were an open revolt
he was not the slightest bit flustered
he had complete confidence that
everything was going to work out all
right
zuckerberg decided it was time to take
facebook beyond its college roots
and introduce it to the general public
the response was stunning membership
doubled
shooting up to 12 million by 2006.
zuckerberg radically altered the
facebook experience again
when for the first time the 23 year old
ceo
invited programmers from around the
world to develop apps
for facebook it was another turning
point
expanding facebook from an insular world
of information
to a platform and it was like the gold
rush
you open up this wonderful platform and
in comes
every kind of developer with every kind
of idea
from video sharing to games to things
that blink to things that
turned into you know ballerinas and
hippos and just every kind of fun
wonderful thing
the platform companies or the operating
system companies
always do the best i mean think of
microsoft you know it had this
ubiquitous windows platform
and all these other companies wrote
programs for windows
you know facebook's really trying to
create itself in that model
and in 2007 microsoft itself
entered the picture this time with a
deal zuckerberg
couldn't turn down and for the first
time the world got a glimpse of what
facebook may really be worth by the time
people were finally getting used to the
idea that anyone would pay a billion
dollars for facebook
microsoft comes along and pays 250
million dollars for
1.6 of the company
it was outrageous it valued the company
at 15 billion
this took facebook from a thing that a
lot of people use to a thing that
everyone was talking about the 15
billion dollar company
but for a 15 billion dollar company
facebook was only making a meager
30 million dollars in profits to remedy
that zuckerberg announced a sweeping new
advertising system in the fall of 2007
one part of it let companies set up
their own facebook pages
and advertise using social ads
lou kerner covers social media and owns
shares in facebook
social ads on facebook are ads where
they would say that your friends meg and
ryan like virgin america
and it turns out not surprisingly that
when you see that your friends like a
product
you're more likely to click on that ad
so social ads have been very successful
on facebook virtually from the beginning
but another part of facebook's new
advertising plan
beacon gave users far more than they
wanted
and they let zuckerberg know about it
zuckerberg's made a lot of mistakes
the next mistake which was a really big
one was beacon
you go to a third-party e-commerce site
and you buy something
and unless you tell it not to really
quickly it's going to go back and tell
all your friends that you just bought a
diamond engagement ring
and obviously you know that sort of
secret feeling can cause a lot of
trouble
there was the the great rallying cry
that facebook ruined christmas
because suddenly everyone's purchases
were being broadcast to
their entire network zuckerberg really
tried to defend it for a while it took
him a while to
realize how wrong it was
on december 5th 2007 zuckerberg made
another apology
he had overreached yet again but as with
previous mistakes
it wouldn't really matter facebook was
just too popular
and it wasn't long before zuckerberg was
loosening up the network's privacy
controls
one more time more than four years after
co-founding facebook
zuckerberg still seemed uneasy in the
public spotlight
what's your next thing you're gonna do
get bought
none of these rumors are true right
um you know this is making me feel very
uncomfortable by 2009
rumors were indeed swirling that
facebook would go public
instead zuckerberg took money from a new
investor
yuri milner ceo of the russian internet
investment firm
digital sky technologies offered a 200
million dollar deal for just 1.9 percent
of the company
deals of that size are kind of never
easy there's a lot of
back and forth this deal was about the
vision that we shared how big this
company can get
everything else was sort of secondary
milner's investment allowed facebook to
continue to expand
and it kept the development of the
company firmly in the hands of its
founder
zuckerberg knew that pushing facebook
advertising even further was the key to
continued growth
for years zuckerberg believed that
facebook was in a unique position
today even with the most advanced
advertising systems that exist
they only have estimates of what
someone's gender might be or what
someone's age might be or what they
might be interested in
but on facebook we know exactly what
gender someone is and exactly how old
they are and exactly what they're
interested in
jeremy smith is chief strategy officer
for second market
a company that brokers shares and
privately held companies which cannot
yet be traded on the public market
what makes facebook so desirable from
the perspective of advertisers
is that they are able to accumulate
information
on their users like nobody else the
funny thing is the users don't really
view it as data
it's themselves it's their information
it's their lives that they're putting on
there but as far as advertisers are
concerned
it is the the holy grail of data
pushing the boundaries of that holy
grail of data was about to get
zuckerberg in trouble again
in december 2009 he revamped the privacy
settings for facebook's then
350 million users unless users
individually restored their settings
previously private information was now
available to everyone on the internet
many people just sort of took that
default
and somewhat inadvertently allowed a lot
of their information to become public
and and many privacy advocates believe
that they didn't explain that
or disclose it sufficiently a firestorm
of complaints
from users and consumer groups forced
zuckerberg to backtrack
again sparking concerns in congress
we are here today to urge facebook's
creator and ceo
mark zuckerberg to revisit this new
policy as soon as possible
we believe facebook should reverse its
policy to begin exploring guidelines
so users know upfront what's happening
adding
fuel to the fire was the surfacing of
still more
instant messages business insider
published messages they said
showed a friend asking then college aged
zuckerberg
why people shared their emails with him
zuckerberg's response
was kurt and profane you know i i mean i
asked him point blank about it
and he was very embarrassed by them by
the fact that he had sent these ims
less than one month later he was put on
the hot seat in a memorably awkward
interview at the all things digital
conference
do you feel like you're violating
people's privacy you know there were
real
learning points and turning points along
the way in terms of
um in terms of building things
if i knew what i knew now then then i
hope i wouldn't have made those mistakes
but
i can't go back and change the past i
can only do what we think is the right
thing going forward
you know anybody who's ever kind of
doubted
what facebook is about or want to
question his integrity i mean they can
they can keep pointing back to that
right to that instance of like
i can't trust that guy that is that is
going to be our check on him
for as long as he remains ceo you know
and in charge of that company
it's going to be like okay you're not
that guy will prove to us that you're
not that guy
chris huffnoggle the director of privacy
programs at the university of california
berkeley
believes mark zuckerberg purposefully
pushes the envelope on privacy
in most situations where a company does
something that's unpopular they have
blow back
they lose the ability to do something
but in facebook's case we have something
called
i call blow forward where they take two
steps forward
there's some type of public reaction and
they just take a little step
back and so over time they've been able
to open up profiles
more and more
[Music]
mark does not think you should be a
different person at work
than you are at the bowling alley in bed
at school you know he basically thinks
you should be consistent across all
these environments so that's a very
radical view for many
older people by the time mark zuckerberg
turned 25 in 2009
he had accumulated so much notoriety
wealth
and power that author ben mesrick had
written a book about him
and the founding of facebook this story
started for me
at an email i received just out of the
blue to my website and eduardo saverin
was angry he wanted to tell his story he
had co-founded facebook with mark
zuckerberg and he said had been kicked
out of the company
and he felt betrayed and he wanted to
talk severan talked to mesrick for six
months about a lawsuit he filed against
his former harvard classmate for
diluting
severan's share of the company according
to mesrick
facebook found out eduardo was talking
to him and they essentially settled with
eduardo
nobody knows for sure what happened but
what i've heard is he got five percent
of facebook and he had to
sign an agreement that said he would
never speak to ben mesrick again
but mesrick already had enough material
for his book
my proposal had leaked out on the web
aaron sorkin saw it
scott rudin saw it so sorkin immediately
signed on to write the screenplay
and everything happened very quickly
from there the pre-release publicity
surrounding the movie
also seemed to force zuckerberg to go on
a pr offensive
the previously pressed shy zuckerberg
was suddenly
everywhere if you build something great
that's what people care about
when people don't care about what
someone says about you in a movie
he gave oprah a tour of his house in
2010 and announced on her show
a 100 million dollar donation to public
schools in newark new jersey
100 million
the social network opened in wide
release on october 1st
2010. people want to go on the internet
and check out their friends so why not
build a website that offers that friends
pictures
profiles i'm talking about taking the
entire social experience of college
and putting it online zuckerberg
complained about his on-screen portrait
as a ruthless socially challenged power
geek with no friends
he said there were factual errors in the
script
frame it as if the whole reason for
making facebook and building something
was because i wanted to get girls or
wanted to get into some kind of
social institution um and i mean the
reality for people who know me is i've
actually been dating the same girl since
before i started facebook
they just can't wrap their head around
the idea that
someone might build something because
they like building things
[Applause]
though he initially said he wouldn't see
the movie zuckerberg ended up taking his
entire staff to it
he even showed up on saturday night live
you ever end up uh
seeing seeing the film that the social
network yeah i i did
cool thanks uh and uh what did you uh
what'd you think it was interesting
thank you to the hollywood farm press
for this extraordinary honor
the social network won a golden globe
award for best dramatic picture
as well as three academy awards
first tunisia now egypt what's next
but to an increasing number of people
around the world
facebook wasn't just a hollywood movie
it was affecting
real life in late 2010
demonstrators started taking to the
streets in tunisia and later
in egypt to protest their repressive
governments by this time
more than 70 percent of facebook's half
a billion plus users
lived outside the united states in egypt
one flash point for the anger was a case
of police brutality at the center of the
protests
was a google employee who ran a facebook
page
walgonnam was the manager in egypt of a
page
that was a memorial to this guy who had
been beaten tortured and killed by the
secret police
[Music]
and that group became very very large
many many hundreds of thousands of
members
during the period leading up to the
revolt against mubarak
[Music]
facebook expedited the ability of people
to express their dissatisfaction which
clearly
sped up the process of these revolts the
governments of tunisia and egypt
fell protesters expressed their
gratitude to facebook on the streets
one named his newborn daughter facebook
and while gonim sang the social
networking sites praises
on cnn i want to meet mark zuckerberg
one day and thank him
i'm talking on behalf of egypt this
revolution started on facebook
when hundreds of thousands of egyptians
started collaborating content you know
like we would post a video on on
facebook they would be shared by 50 000
people
on their walls within few hours
facebook itself was was very quick to
try to distance
themselves from that political activity
i mean obviously
they supported it but they don't really
want to be seen as a tool of change
because obviously facebook wants to be
active in regimes like china
they don't necessarily want themselves
viewed as a tool of insurgency
zuckerberg has taken on a personal goal
that might help
him with his mission to connect the
world he says he spends an hour a day
studying chinese
which could potentially help him gain a
billion new friends
it's the fastest growing and the biggest
internet market in the world there are
hundreds of millions of users
and his mission is incomplete if he's
not in china mark zuckerberg's power had
never been greater
and once again speculation grew that he
would take his company public
despite enormous pressure zuckerberg has
been hesitant to pull the trigger and
cash in
100 years 200 years from now what's
going to be more important the money
right or the fact that he has had this
kind of impact or the fact that he's
you know executed and developed
and helped evolve this thing that is
more than just a technology site
and it's more than just a website and so
i think that's why it's never been about
money
and it's never been about status when
companies go public
it's a tremendous strain on the
management and in fact on top of all of
that
when you go public you you open yourself
up to even greater government scrutiny
aware of that scrutiny facebook has
amped up their presence in washington
with a team that includes several former
white house aides and influential
capitol hill insiders
political official after political
official will tell you
if you are absent from the debate um
you're
likely to be the person who kind of gets
cut out
and so presence in that debate
particularly when
you know google and yahoo and microsoft
and a number of other very large players
are spending a lot on lobbying is a
mistake
today several facebook founders
including mark's friends and classmates
have left the company to start new
ventures on their own
they've been dubbed the facebook mafia
but much of silicon valley talent is on
their way in
top programmers are leaving companies
like google to be a part of zuckerberg's
momentum
and facebook and google the two internet
behemoths are competing in
other ways ryan single is a staff writer
for wired magazine
facebook and google's relationship is
pretty simple they really they just
don't like each other
they're really i mean they're competing
cultures um
you know facebook was sort of young
brash
wild and google is like you know an
algorithm
company like these are guys that like
any problem there's got to be a way that
they can write a little algorithm
that'll fix it
it's clear that google missed the rise
of social and eric schmidt has has
admitted to
to being flat-footed around facebook and
around social
they've tried a number of things most
spectacularly the buzz social network
that just hasn't worked then in may of
2011
facebook was embarrassed when it was
revealed that they had launched
a secret attack on google facebook is
doing damage control after revelations
it hired a pr
firm to plant negative stories about
google
facebook claimed publicly it was not a
smear campaign
but the exchange revealed just how
vicious the competition has become
the whole burst in marcello flap was was
really just an in-your-face
expression of the animosity that has
sprung up not only between these two
companies but almost the personal
shakespearean drama that's playing out
between google and between facebook
which frankly has a lot of former
google execs who would like nothing more
than to supplant their former company
you can't underestimate how driven mark
zuckerberg really is
he says his mission is to you know make
the world more open a better place his
mission is also to be
number one right he wants to be you know
inscribed on granite
above bill gates i think he is well on
his way
like gates another harvard dropout
zuckerberg is a fierce competitor
he moved quickly to vanquish rivals
google and twitter
with a stunning acquisition in april
2012
instagram is off the market in an
instant
facebook likes the photo sharing app so
much it's paying
1 billion dollars for it in cash and
shares
ahead of its ipo but the app is free and
has
little known revenue still facebook may
need instagram more than instagram needs
the money instagram has become a photo
sharing competitor and a social network
all its own it was considered a radical
and
defensive move facebook cannot take any
chance
that any other social network oriented
toward photos
could really get traction that would
come you know com
compare to theirs and i think so there's
a preemptive quality to this
also i think almost certainly google was
interested
and probably maybe forced facebook to
act now
one month later facebook finally went
public
in the largest ipo on record for an
internet company
making mark zuckerberg a
multi-billionaire this is an awesome
moment
the ceo and hoodie and sneakers retain
tight control of his company with 57
of shareholder voting rights facebook
has literally changed the world we've
moved
from the country to the village to the
town to facebook it's just getting
started
too i think it's just going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger
for a site that's able to move from
the dorm room to a site where you know
my 80 year old mother
and myself and my chiropractor and my
third grade class all reunites on the
site and we all have something to talk
about
it's an achievement zuckerberg is just
as visionary as steve jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as bill gates
but he's not dealing with a piece of
gadget
he's not dealing with some program
he's dealing with our lives he's dealing
with our identities
so that's why i think we're all going to
have to kind of keep him in check
in a way we make decisions at facebook
not optimizing for you know what is
going to happen in the next year but
what's going to set us up to really be
in this world where every product
experience that you have is social and
that's all powered by facebook